[Música]
e este é o nosso tubo de escape a 0 com
coca cola o lado pessoal de quem fala da
que sejam muito bem vindos a mais é o
melhor que o estrago de que novamente um
vídeo com a minha bicicleta eu a vi já
traz cumprir um brinquedo que por acaso
testar aqui com um brinquedo um tubo de
escape é basicamente não tem isso na
minha bicicleta e fez um mundial muito
barulho de uma moto mas muitos de vocês
comentaram time está por fazer de forma
que ainda está para fazer em casa com
uma garrafa destas plástico cartão então
hoje nós vamos tentar fazer essas formas
quiserem que vocês recomendaram embaixo
os brinquedos caros do rio diminui dos
feitos hoje vamos fazer coisas em casa e
eu também que vem chegar na internet
fora mas fazer um tubo de escape para
bicicleta caseiras e eu só encontrei um
que com uma garrafa e também com cartões
mas dessa forma não usar porque
precisamente o brinquedo uso dessa forma
então eu não vou usar outra vez mas eu
acho que com nossa garrafa de coca cola
vai funcionar e eu ainda tenho outra que
eu fazia quando era muito porque eu
tinha uns 11 12 anos que usava esta
forma uma lata de coca-cola eu não sei
se estava em más mas fiquei primeiro
jato em que nossa bicicleta olha só
vamos fechar os olhos porque só vamos lá
fazer então o nosso buscar porque a 0
mas antes pessoal da capacidade muito à
equipe neste vídeo ser é muito
importante mesmo se vocês deixarem
laicos mais vídeos meus você
recomendados para vocês se vocês não
deixaram lá e eu não vou ter visões que
nossos governos meus filhos e eu vou
ficar aqui
[Aplausos]
3 isso vocês não forem inscritos no
canal e irmãos ea tmn possibilitou o
desvio é para lá que eu construí pessoal
nosso tubo de escape para bicicleta e eu
tenho que duas formas queda coca cola em
garrafa e da coca cola é o ataque é que
o vasco vai funcionar melhor
esta queda lapa meu faz muito barulho de
moto a ser pais mesmo muito pelo meio
antigamente fazia então vamos deixar
essa profissão vamos fazer devagar vai
ter como é que uma chance está em
primeiro lugar uma cueca em primeiro
lugar vamos ter que tirar a coca cola é
que assim como não quero expressar a
coca cola porque é muito burro é muito
bom coca-cola eu vou deixar aqui ó
neste pouquinho que brad miller sou eu
sou eu que vou ver meu só viver essa
coca cola está muito à vontade do
governo é muita e tom o cachorro gasto
explodissem uma pinha olha aí já
expressei acaba aqui dentro tem muita
coisa que eu vou beber um pouquinho sua
alma você agora tenho certeza como
embaixo do assento para mim pegas em
seriados iphone que conseguiu em casa
que me deixou sair do primeiro é esse
michel começou e como também para lá
fora o pessoal entende que nossa guerra
fase e agora vamos ter que fechar nesta
que vai ser nosso tubo de escape para a
bicicleta e nós vamos fazer com isso
como é que está a fazer um livro com
vocês ou então não perguntaram mas
poderá mesmo eu apenas vou ter que
segurar os cartões que já foi usado no
brinquedo mas que eu já estou aqui minha
garrafa e como é que vou fazer isso ó é
só pegar um x-ato a lei precisa
realmente foi o que eu vi na internet
que só cortar assim temos que cortar
assim um pouco agora aqui do outro lado
assim e agora contar aqui
automaticamente atende esse cartão eu
acho que você já deve estar o que eu vou
fazer né basta só colares na bicicleta e
o cartão fica na roda não vai fazer um
barulho muito mas muito mais potente
só assim já faz muito barulho mas nem
este nem sequer é outra vez mais gosta
disto é nossa mas vamos tentar tudo
junto
junto foi aqui
o fone como eu nunca vi isso
não sei nem técnica por uma comecei a
descobrir o que é isto só se quiserem
ver um vídeo vou tentar saber por que
estou fora mas agora vídeo de bicicleta
agora para lá só ataque nossa bicicleta
em cima da bancada 321 muito mais
barulho mesmo aí eu voltei agora só que
é o passo mais básico que colar o nosso
carro disse cleto
olha só que o cara se irregular isso
tudo neves e clécio ele é e para além
dos cientistas ou 1 km
com isso o mau começo mal uma falta tudo
o que aconteceu contra o coxa tenta
colar esse segmento está quase pronta
eu acho que o nosso tubo de escape está
muito outros bem que eu tenho aqui um
logótipo da coca cola mas acho que não
faz mal a sua e eu vou fazer isso aqui
de forma um pouco improvisada mas ainda
dá pra fazer muito melhor porque
circular uma cartolina
por dentro uma carrinha toda preta vai
parecer que a coca cola está
completamente cheia então as pessoas vão
ficar a olhar como essa pessoa tá na
bicicleta com uma coca-cola cheque mas
como isto só fazer um protótipo eu não
vou fazer dessa forma mas não seja em
casa podem fazer sim eu caí para os
jovens isso eu nem pensava 'que
funcionar tão bem assim mas vamos lá 321
faltava calma calma se eu fizer uma
pequena obra neste plástico eu acho que
ainda vai funcionar não vamos lá só vou
estar a bicicleta por bora lá pessoal tá
tudo que fora vamos lá ver então se isso
funciona realmente quando eu estivera na
bicicleta
vamos lá olha começou aqui em baixo não
só como é que fica o sol fica muito
grande tubo de escape imaginam ter mesmo
carolina lemos vai você tá cheia para lá
estar 321 passado que isto não está a
funcionar muito bem está controlado
eu acho que o corinthians bate uma
garrafa ficou descontrolado mas acho que
dá pra andar e garrafa só a lutar contra
isto não estava a ter aqui porque
garrafa é muito grande onde correr um
pouco mal mas o próximo ano vai dar
muito muito sério é o tubo de escape uma
escola está a dar muito certo porque eu
já tenho há muito tempo atrás eu espero
que funcione mas faz muito barulho mota
sério mas muito alto mesmo primeiro vôo
fez para este é só que chega com um
pouco atrás
assim jovens e dar-lhes um vai e não
volta mas é muito fraquinho tão fácil eu
vou ver uma estrutura de capital não
funcionou melhor
agora vai funcionar
este ano tudo indica por a minha
bicicleta olha aí a única coisa que
funcionou foi ter as mãos sujas o i e ii
é e eu pendurei dos ei eu só como ficou
e agora tem muita cola químico tiro isso
a princípio meu acervo está a correr
muito mal bom visto que esta forma não
funcionou muito bem e vamos fazer outra
forma tudo diz cá para lá já estamos
aqui no balcão e vejam só como estão as
minhas mãos
olha aí tá tudo sujo
os james eu vou contratar alguém para
limpar isso é estranho
os jovens só espaço aqui mesmo tempo que
não vou precisar qualquer com nené nunca
se polícia coorpin call to provide de
uma coisa a cair acabou a nossa cola
só desta forma é muito simples que eu
acho que é que mais funciona para
administrar agora são só vocês em casa
só tem que fazer com uma coisa vai
funcionar muito maior
é só pisar em a nossa lata de coca cola
em 32 o isso nos marcou bem como eu
queria que eu tenho é grande só vou
buscar outra lata agora foi só para
quando um upgrade no pé é porque estava
e foi agora é que vamos fazer agora é só
um cara lá tudo bem que foi só desta
forma esta forma super importante ela
também fica precisamente assim agora
vamos montar o nosso tubo de escape
minha bicicleta
a única coisa que temos que fazer é
colocar a lata é que bem por trás da
roda e depois temos que importar muito
vaiado assim tudo fica mais ou menos
e agora é só mandar para fora
para ele não basta só agora sim a
questões pronto 321 vai o gol
agora funciona pois mesmo modo
[Música]
ae
op
só há uma dificuldade em usar isto
buscapé que a bicicleta fica muito
instável e fica quase incontrolável e
provavelmente estragar o pneu tem um
bairro mas realmente o sonho mais
parecia uma motosserra saltar vocês
podem voltar a encaixar vou tentar me
tira a tampa para lá olha só
e este é o nosso tubo de escape a 0 com
coca cola
o gol
[Música]
no outro
[Aplausos]
o ouro já não fazia está muito tempo ser
eu próprio estou impressionado é um som
mais por ser uma meta possível é só
porque estou aqui é metal como tal então
é preciso fazer seguro normalmente
juntos cartões ou e papel e plástico
então um tal faz muito muita diferença
eu vou andar mais eu quero andar maior
[Aplausos]
for o pessoal só que aconteceu e está
tudo em aberto é porque o que está
acontecendo aqui é que a roda está a
andar muito rápido e essa fricção no
total vai testando é por isso que ela
abra isso é muito perigoso que sua não
usa muita técnica porque isso é só para
andar um pouco tal como eu fiz aqui
porque pode ser muito perigoso vocês
podem ver e eu não quero que isso
aconteça então tenho muito cuidado mesmo
e agora é só usar outro lado é bom mas
vamos aprendendo agora para quem só
estamos aqui novamente no balcão vejam
só como é que está tudo pra tudo uma
porcaria de jesus papel espalhada ou na
bancada já que mais não tinha as provas
também pra nada se faz só espero que a
gente não está aqui diz filho já sabe
quanto o nosso email é que neste trilho
e só fique bem e até a próxima
[Música]